welcome to this special edition of
hannity and happy passover and good
friday everyone i'm tammy bruce in for
sean and tonight we are at the bitter
end of yet another terrible week for joe
biden dreadful economic news mayhem at
the southern border and poll numbers
lower than ever before not only is biden
underwater by double digits in five new
polls but he is also struggling in two
key demographics that democrats
desperately need to win elections
according to quinnipiac only 26
of hispanics now approve of biden's
performance in the white house and
gallup found that biden is also
hemorrhaging support among young voters
only 39 of generation z and 41 of
millennials approve of joe biden tonight
bad poll numbers are just the beginning
of biden's problems this week president
biden you've perhaps seen this
looked lost and confused and at one
point he attempted to shake hands with
someone who wasn't there and during a
speech joe biden claimed that he used to
be a full professor at the university of
pennsylvania watch this
i've been impressed i've been on a lot
of university campuses matter of fact
for four years i was a full professor at
the university of pennsylvania and this
is really an impressive place
yeah yeah that's just not true however
at one point the university did pay
biden almost a million dollars to be an
honorary professor that's really nice
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else